a long line of ambulances outside a
covert 19 hospital in the state of
gujarat
inside are patients struggling to
breathe and waiting for a bed to become
available
gujarat is one of many states where the
hospitals are overcrowded and they don't
have enough equipment or healthcare
workers to deal with the current
caseload
the ambulances bring in the patients who
are on oxygen supply
some of them are critical and they're
admitted first as soon as the beds with
ventilators are available
the patients who are on oxygen supply
through the venturi masks are given that
in 108 ambulances
as patients wait for beds the families
of the dead
mourn for their loved ones nowhere is
the situation as
bad as in the state of maharashtra where
migrant workers crowded bus and train
terminals
after more restrictions were announced
the closing down of all but essential
services has seen many
daily wage earners lose their jobs they
want to travel to their home states
afraid the government might shut down
public transport as it did last year
it's the common man who suffers the most
i have come here from uttar pradesh i
have no russian card or any other local
documents
only those who are local and have a
russian card will get groceries
outsiders don't get anything at all how
will migrant workers feed themselves
that's why they are leaving for their
villages
state leader said he had no choice but
to impose the restrictions
this disease is spreading at a very
horrifying pace i say horrifying because
today's number of positive cases in the
state
is highest so far maharashtra's 125
million people
will only be allowed to go out for work
and shop for essential supplies
including groceries and medicines
until the end of april as india
witnesses the world's
biggest surge in cases the health
ministry says it will
fast track emergency approvals for the
pfizer
moderna and johnson johnson vaccines
that's amid continuing reports of
vaccine shortages in the country
which produces 60 percent of all the
vaccines
in the world elizabeth al jazeera new
delhi